film George with
and Kieran
um the traditional the traditional
distribution model you know as indie
filmmakers is pretty much broken at this
point absolutely and traditionally you
know you go down that Avenue of
distribution and the filmmaker is you
know you're lucky as a filmmaker to
maybe recoup three percent of all
revenue and all profit generated from
distributing a film in the traditional
manner that's what you end up with
unfortunately so self distribution
definitely puts it back the control back
in the filmmakers hands as an
independent filmmaker access to fellow
independent filmmakers you know we we
choose to do this out of passion and we
have to make a lot of sacrifices but you
know what just keep at it and it'll
happen it'll happen for sure but we got
to stick together as filmmakers to and
be open to helping one another because
we're at an interesting time right now
the distribution wheel is changing and
you know we have to rise as filmmakers
to make it happen